hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast isolation and
characterization of exosomes and ekta's
ohms i am dr. chad schwartz senior
application scientist at beckman coulter
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational webinar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by beckman coulter
beckman coulter is a leader in central
Gatien and flow cytometry and has long
been an innovator and particle
characterization lab automation and
genomics that when culture products are
used at the forefront of important areas
of investigation and discovery for more
information please visit beckman coulter
com we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
the lower left of the presentation
window will try to answer as many
questions as we can you can enlarge a
slide window by clicking on the green by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problems to the green Q&A button I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
Suresh MIT meth 'venom dr. Mathur vanin
is a laboratory head in the department
of biochemistry and genetics at latrobe
Ian Institute for molecular science the
math of an in laboratory developed and
maintains two widely used databases for
X ISM and extracellular vesicles EXO
Carta and vesicle pedia and has been
performing pioneering research on
exosomes for the last eight years today
he will tell us about a global pro do do
genomics analysis that is lab performed
which has unveiled the secretion of
mutant proteins that are implicated in
cancer progression through v's before we
get started I would like to ask a few
poll questions
our first question is what separation
technique are you currently using to
isolate exosomes also gentrification or
differential gradient affinity capture
size exclusion or precipitation reagents
will give the audience 15 to 20 seconds
to answer and I will come back with the
results all right great the majority of
folks use ultra Gatien or differential
gradient at 62.3 percent 13.2 percent of
you use affinity capture size exclusion
comes in at 6.6 percent and
precipitation reagents at seventeen
point nine percent our second and final
poll question is populating now and it
is what is your sample source for
extracting exosomes either tissue cell
culture blood urine plasma or other
again will give the audience a bit of
time to answer
alright it looks like the majority of
everyone in attendance here is using
cell culture at forty one point nine
percent plasma is our second highest at
twenty percent followed by blood and
then tissue then urine and there's also
another at ten point five percent thank
you everyone for your answers and I will
now turn it over to dr. Mathur vannin
for his presentation thanks Chad thanks
for the kind introduction so um today as
we spoke about I'm going to talk about
isolation and characterization of
exosomes and ekta zones these are two
different type of extracellular vesicles
that the cells secrete in the
physiological and pathological
conditions so I'm just going to share
our lab experience in isolating and
characterizing these extracellular
vesicles so prior to going into the
extracellular vesicles we all know about
the classical and non classical way of
protein secretion most importantly the
classical separation pathway which
involves the ER and golgi there has been
very well characterized over the years
and the protein which is about to be
secreted should have a signal peptide
and then that gets cleaved off and then
these proteins are then targeted towards
to be separated out from these cells so
um recently over the last three decades
we know about some of the some of the
ways that the nonclassical secretion
mechanisms or by which proteins are
secreted other than the ER and golgi
pathway for example like they know about
excess
which are small vesicles that are
separated out by the cells and these
doesn't follow the canonical of the
classical secretory pathway similarly we
have something called as ectodomain
shedding or shed shedding of plasma
membrane so imagine there are a lot of
plasma membrane proteins which are
present in the cell and these can be
cleaved off by extracellular proteases
which can then cleave this particular
domain or which can be the ectoderm line
and that can be shed into the
extracellular space and that can have a
functional implication on either
stimulating recipient cell or then
trying to do some signaling pathway in
the recipe in cell as well and in other
ways where there are other mechanisms by
which a protein can pass through the
plasma membrane channels through there
and this is a rare mechanism where not
many proteins are being reported by that
kind of mechanism and lastly I just want
to emphasize on the shedding
microvesicles or alternatively which are
called as actors ohms which are coming
from the plasma membrane plumbing again
there's a controversy in the field where
we talk about these vesicles as together
and we sometimes call them in a mixer
way where we call microvesicles for both
of them and there's no standardization
as such but people in the field are
trying to create one and currently this
is what we have so let's focus on
exosomes these are secreted nano
vesicles from these cells as you can see
once there is a receptor which is
internalized and then that leads to the
formation of early endosomes the early
endosomes then which you to form late
endosomes where there are intraluminal
vesicles which are happening by the
invagination of the limiting membrane
and this results in the formation of
small intraluminal vesicles inside the
late endosomes so now the late endosomes
can partake to function in either go
into the degradative pathway where it
can fuse with the lysosome
or it can take the exercising pathway
where the late endosomes can fuse with
the plasma membrane and release its
contents into the extracellular space so
upon release the intraluminal vesicles
which are the small vesicles which our
friends present inside the late
endosomes are referred to as exosomes so
um recently our studies have shown that
these exosomes have a lot of
physiological functions where they can
stimulate signaling pathway in the
recipient cells as well as transfer the
proteins and RNA content to the
recipient cell so what we have done in
the lab like we have isolated and exeter
exosome from cell lines and blood plasma
which is good that a lot of people in
the whole that Chad conducted had people
have been isolating into zones from cell
culture media and also from plasma so we
had done a comparative analysis to see
which methods are better in isolating
exosomes to homogeneity when I say
homogeneity again when we look in terms
of the vesicle characteristics we also
look in terms of markers which are known
to be present in the vesicles the extra
cell are vesicles and then we compare
these three methods and say okay which
is the method that which is not as
cumbersome but also isolates a pure of
population of Exeter's so we use the
commonly used methodologies that was
currently at that time so this was um
probably now three four five years old
and especially the cell line study was
done for years old but the plasma study
was done two years ago which was
published in 2013 so we initially took
differential centrifugation coupled with
audra centrifugation which is currently
the gold standard in terms of isolating
these vesicles when I say gold standard
because all the other techniques we have
even though there may be robust there
some inherent problems with some of the
isolation methods but if you want to
capture the whole population of exosomes
currently lot of the labs
use different certification and alpha
interrogation and is one of the
instrument that is available to many
labs and where we not have to have any
specialized instruments for these so
this is what we did we are completely
isolated exosomes from differential
identification then we also did an
optical density gradient centrifugation
and previously a lot of researcher used
to use sucrose clarity sucrose gradient
density gradient Santa fication as well
but based on prior literature a lot of
people were able to show that the
sucrose density gradient centrifugation
was not able to separate viruses from
extrasolar be sequence and as well as
sucrose is not it's toxic to the cells
when you take the extracellular vesicles
from these and try to do some functional
studies with that you might you might
introduce some toxic biases to the
culture medium and also the optical
density gradient solution have an I
sophomoric solution which keeps in terms
of there's no problems across Moses in
there and you might not have sample loss
and your ex's own integrity is preserved
and most importantly when you are trying
to do some functional analysis the
exosomes are indeed functional for quite
some time so lastly we used a human
affinity pull down approach which people
used and in this case we used at camp
but this can be used on any other
surface antigen that we think is present
in exosomes we the main reason we
started using headcam was this these
kind of beads were commercially
available and it is easy for many labs
to purchase and do the analysis plus
prior to that two other studies the
isolated exosomes from serum of variant
and lung cancer patients and they were
using F kin and develop beats so the
purpose is to identify which are the
better methods in isolating exosomes and
then we compare these methods and say
what is
isolating pure population and what is
easier to use and things and things like
that so this is summary of the outcome
which was identified from the two
studies as you can see when we use the
seller and cultural media again this is
when I talk about the cell line it is a
colorectal cancer cell line called lim
1863 where these are organized these are
not against el these grow a suspension
and these cells were easy to culture and
we use that for our all our purposes so
when we did the differential
centrifugation from these I'm gonna say
differential simplification it is
isolating the exosomes by a hundred
thousand g you spin them down for
100,000 g41 are and you wash them with
PBS ice-cold PBS and and then you have
the pellet and the pellets we call it as
crude exosomes and optical density
gradient centrifugation performed better
than the density gradient centrifugation
as you can see here but the important
thing was the immediate immunoaffinity
pull down perform better than the
optical and density gradient
centrifugation here but as the
immunoaffinity pull down was done on app
can visit which is epithelial cell
adhesion molecule which is present in a
lot of epithelial cells and we were able
to isolate them and when you looked at
the proteomic profile of the exosomes
isolated from these three methodologies
we were able to get more X's on like
signature in the immune or an takuna
half technology is that this particular
study was done and when I was a postdoc
in Richard Simpsons lab who's well known
for a studio mix work and isolation
technologies so later on when we started
the group and we also were interested in
plasma and vascular because we wanted to
do a lot of patient samples and we
wanted to identify biomarkers and
validate those biomarkers in the patient
samples in a robust and the easier way
so for that reason we isolated we
compare these three methods in terms of
the norm
used methods which is the differential
centrifugation optical and
immunoaffinity follow so one of the
problems with plasma as we all know in
terms us it has a lot of proteins which
are highly abundant there are 20
proteins which make up close to ninety
two percent of the plasma protein
composition and very little like say the
the proteins of our interest may be
present in very few amount so to deplete
that or to enrich our protein of
interest a lot of people do the
depletion strategies where they try to
do deplete the albumin content or try to
enrich for the proteins of choice by
using an antibody based pulled on
methods so exosomes has a good good
advantage already here because when we
isolate exosomes be kind of deplete a
lot of these abundant proteins already
so it's naturally a very good source of
disease or biomarkers studies so for
this case we started using plasma so as
we all know when we did the differential
certification be the isolated exosomes
did a proteomic analysis of these
vesicles and we found out that the
exosomes isolated by the crew by the
differential duplication was big crew
and it had a lot of proteinaceous
background which is coming from albumin
and many other plasma abundant proteins
right and when we did the email affinity
program which again did not work as well
as it worked in cell lines probably
because of the the unavailability of at
camp positive exosomes because these
plasma are from normal normal person and
is not from patient samples we pulled
plasma from a lot of normal people and
then we started doing these analysis but
optical density gradient centrifugation
was the better method compared to these
three where we could isolate better
exosomes which is devoid of some of the
contaminants that you normally see in
plasma studies including
and and other abundant calf serum
proteins so I'm the the take home
message from this slide is the
methodology of choice depends on the
sample that you are using and also the
purpose for example if you are
interested in a functional study or
interested in something characterizing
these basic rules for better
understanding then you would you would
better do better purification analysis
like an optical density gradient
centrifugation or if you want something
like I want it to be quick and robust
where I have a lot of patient samples I
can't do a density gradient at the
sample amount that i have is very low
then you end up choosing other methods
like amino going to be pulled on all the
commercial kits which are available
which are quick and dirty where you can
isolate things faster but again we all
accept that they are pretty dirty where
you also isolate many other protein
contaminants other than extra salah
bicycles so now in addition to that this
is one question which we always get in
many conferences and even in many other
reviews as well so how stable are
exosomes all right so we talk about
exosomes extra saliva signals and we
talked about that we can use them as
biomarkers and we all know there's a lot
of patient samples which are being
stored in repositories and you can
collect samples which have been 20 years
or older 25 years old and repositories
and can we use these samples can we go
back to the clinicians and ask all fresh
samples or how long the exosomes are
stable is there any integrity problem
for them is there some of the proteins
which are kind of getting degraded so to
address this question initially what we
started doing is when we started
isolating exosomes from the plasma we
observed that we did not find some of
the canonical so-called markers which
were being referred to at that point of
a time like Alex and th you know one we
could not find Alex ante
normal plasma but in patient plasma you
can detect them in a minimal amount but
not in normal plasma so we started
questioning why are we not seeing alex
antiaging 101 are we isolating vesicles
which are not exosomes or is there any
other type of vesicles or is the
vesicles bursting out or they're not
stable and plasma there are a lot of
questions to address for this so we took
an approach where we wanted to have a
standard a spike in standard to see
whether these are stable so we took
exosomes from this cone rectal cancer
cell line limb 1863 and then spike them
into plasma one mil of plasma and then
we store them at various temperatures in
triplicates for various armed or really
engaged as you can see restore them in
10 days 30 days and 90 days in four
degree minus 20 minus 80 and also in 37
degree celsius then at various time
points we recover this plasma and then
spin it down to isolated by the
differential centrifugation method and
then be probed it for western blotting
for tsg101 because tsg101 is abundant in
the excess ohms that we spiked in and we
were able to able to identify tsg101 in
in the isolated exosomes which we are
incubated with the plasma so when we
recovered these exosomes from when we
recover these exosomes it was clear that
we were able to see that exosomes are
stable for three months and they were
very stable in minus 80 followed by
minus 20 and Ford agree to an extent but
not for long in four degrees but minus
80 they were quite stable for three
months so now let's go to the next topic
in terms of what is the current study
most of them what I present it was
published but I just wanted to give a
brief overview but in this case we all
know there are three types of
extracellular vesicles based on the
biogenesis and we're not talking about
the sample type we are not talking about
what cell it is secreting but based on
the biogenesis that we know
one is exosomes which are small vesicles
secreted by P multivesicular bodies and
then the sector zones are shedding
microwave signals which is coming from
loving from the plasma membrane and
lastly the apoptotic bodies which are
coming duty apoptosis so um the problem
currently in the field is like we don't
know the most of the characteristics of
other vesicles well they're well
established on some of the
characteristics of exosomes is
relatively well understood compared to
hectors ohms and apoptotic bodies we
know the size is between 30 to 1 50
nanometer because when we do the
nanoparticle tracking and many other
size based analysis we now realize that
these exosomes can go up to 150
nanometers and then the shedding
microvesicles this is what the consensus
is that it can go from 100 to 1000
nanometer and the apoptotic bodies can
go up till 5 micrometer and we know
about the bargains pathways the density
of exosomes s 1 point 10 to 1 point 1 4
which is considered to be in the field
but we don't know the density in which
the actors ohms or the apoptotic bodies
and settling and some of the markers
that we think which we are currently
thinking was Alex tsg101 cd63 cd81 and
cd9 but Hector zones we don't know about
markers and also operatic bodies and if
you want to read more about it you can
see lot all at all which talks about the
minimal requirements of publishing on
extracellular vesicles where they talk
about the problems in terms of
identified identifying markers so even
though we think Alex and thi minus 1 or
markers but they are exosome Enbridge
proteins and they are not Marcus they
are also present in exosomes to an extra
so the take home message here is EV
subtypes are not well characterized and
then despite separate violinists pathway
the definitive markers or non-existence
this is one of the burning questions in
the field and a lot of people are trying
to address this so I'm adding what is
important right when we talk about the
extra set of vesicles the X's on the
nectar zones do we really need to have
markers do we need to differentiate it
so again it depends like as I said how
the isolation method depends on the only
on your on what you're trying to do
similarly the EV subtype is also
important in many cases like in some
cases let's say we are only looking in
terms of disease biomarkers where we are
only trying to identify whether they can
find something to discriminate between a
normal and the deceased patient in those
cases I don't think it matters because
as long as you can differentiate between
a normal and a patient regardless of
what bicycle type it is it's still good
but in some cases or in most of the
cases you can say it doesn't matter
because if we wanted to identify the
functionality or what these vesicles
play it's important to purify these
vesicles to homogeneity and then we can
study the precise functional role of
this EDS and even understand more about
the biogenesis pathway if we exactly
know the precise and markers so as we
said it's it is important based on your
based on what you're trying to be so
what we did for this particular project
is we isolated extracellular vesicles
from three cell lines and we chose three
cell lines which is to neuroblastoma
cell lines which is commonly used in
many labs one is the SH s yyy and then
the sk + b2 cell line which is the more
aggressive neuroblastoma cell line and
then one colorectal cell in column 1 to
15 so we isolated EBS by the commonly
used methodologies where we use the
differential centrifugation we spun the
cultural media and after 24 hours but
500,000 g for 10 minutes and then two
and two thousand g for 20 minutes just
to pellet down these cells and then we
apoptotic gloves or
or bigger that the d'bries which are
coming out from the apoptosis and we
discard those pellets and then we get
the supernatant centrifuge into 10,000 g
to isolate the bigger vesicles which
could be called as the crude actors ohms
the pellet and then we get the
supernatant and center field trip to
100,000 g 2 1 R to get a crude exosome
pellet so we also take the supernatant
prick prior to that and send future
ectly 200,000 g without doing a 10,000 g
and then subject that to optical density
gradient centrifugation here you have a
mixed population of smaller and bigger
vesicles and we wanted to separate these
and see what kind of vesicles we get
from the optical density gradient
certification so um one important thing
for all these analysis any kind of
extrasolar vehicles that you do is it's
important that you do a cell viability
assay so you need to know what is the
cell that that you normally have and
what is the cell that that you have at
that particular point so which we
routinely routinely perform in the lab
here you can see the percentage of my
ability cell viability in sh5 and
neuroblastoma cell line where the cells
are surviving more than ninety
one-percent viable cells and then as you
can see we also used instead of serum
fetal calf serum we used insulin
transfer in selenium which is another
component which can be substituted for
instead of serum if you want a
serum-free media we use it where it has
a lot of growth factors which can
stimulate the cells again i emphasize
caution in using this because you need
to first see some cells don't like ideas
because there's more apoptosis in them
some cells like it but the insulin also
promotes a lot of procreative signal in
there and you need to have a proper
control while doing this while you can
see when we compared with FCS and also
bit and without ice ideas you can see
there's not much cell that but when we
incubated back the docs you listen you
can see there is
edge of caspase-3 and there is sell that
at 48 hours you can see by clipart as
well so again it would be good for any
of you if you are trying to do any
essays or any functionalities with extra
seller vesicles you better have to have
a control saying that your cell
viability is quite good so then we took
the excess ella vesicles which was spun
200,000 g and then we can be separated
them by optical density gradient
centrifugation and isolate the fractions
and probe for a Western for Alex and th
0 1 in different fractions as you can
see here Alex engage one-on-one were
enriched in the seventh fraction which
is 1.10 but was present in multiple
fractions so the optical density
gradient simplification that we perform
was done bailed on sedimentation which
is meaning you're loading the sample on
top of the of the column and not on the
bottom where you put the sample first
and then load all the the eye reduction
or gradient and also you can see the 10k
or the ectoderm prelate where you can
see Alex and tsg101 the so-called
markers of exosomes are also present in
this ectodermal population or the cruda
presumes here so in the lab and as we
all know we struggled to isolate
exigence when I say struggle to isolate
exosomes we do a lot of cell culture we
have a lot of plates we culture a lot of
cells to get enough mode of exosomes to
do the whole prep so we can't afford to
do or spend a lot of protein in multiple
methods like BCA or bradford so what we
try to do is quant the amount of protein
that is present in extracellular
vesicles by sensitive methods like cyber
Rudy so this methodology helps us to
Quantico grams level where we use very
little micro liter of sample and we can
quant the amount of protein relative to
each other so this is an image that
you're seeing on where the quantity
quantify the amount of protein
that is present in the fractions that
was collected by a from optical density
gradient centrifugation as you can see
the seventh fraction which had the Alex
and th 11 were had high amounts of
protein in one of the runs and then we
repeated this multiple times based on
the optimized the density gradient where
we are working with a different gradient
centrifugation system instead of five to
forty percent we are playing up with the
density gradient and we are able to get
a high amount of protein in the tenth
fraction which is the higher density
fraction as you can see the exothermic
fraction is one point 10 which is
enriched in there but there is also a
lot of protein in 1.12 but there was
less Alex and tease your mobile so we
have repeated this multiple times in
many other cell lines and even in pi y
and as you can see that the tenth
fraction always had more amount of
protein and which is corresponding to
1.20 but the accessible fraction had
some protein but mainly the mainly the
sorry once again it's a motion detectors
sorry I apologize for that so it's a
motion detectors it ended at Kennedy so
as you can see the tenth fraction had a
lot of protein in there but we want your
curious to see what our this one of the
vesicles which are present in the ten
fraction so now you can see that I go to
the best in you can see that the Alex
integer in the world or present in our
English in the seventh fraction but the
tent and the ninth fraction had a very
low amount of Alex engaging oh no one
even though they had a lot of protein
right so they had a lot of protein but
then what are these proteins so we were
curious to see and then we wanted to
characterize these EV subtypes so we
took those fractions 1.10 which
corresponds to exosomes 1.14 and above
which corresponds to the bigger basic
rules and then we also have a cruel 10k
palette
and then the whole cell lysate as well
you can see that the Alex was present in
both but the marker which is the GM 130
that is supposed to so sure that if
there is any epic losses and there was
not present in any of those things
suggesting that the isolation was pretty
good so then we went on to characterize
these extracellular vesicles subtypes by
biophysical methods so the biophysical
methods are important to show the size
and shape of these vesicles as you can
see here the the seventh fraction or the
1.10 fraction which is isolated by the
optical density gradient you can see the
vesicles which are smaller but when he
went to the higher density fraction you
had a bigger vesicles which are more
than 200 nanometers in diameter it was
consistent also in the 10k pellet or
which was like the cruel act ozone
pellet which we call as such you can see
the fiber cells had bigger vesicles and
then even the limb 115 the colorectal
cancer cell line I said it also had
bigger bicycles what what was
interesting you can see that is these
vesicles are not as as homogeneous and
you can see there are bigger vesicles
where they are where are their stressed
because of the centrifugation protocol
and when we see that in the optical
density gradient centrifugation we can
clearly see that some of the bigger
vesicles don't make it up hundred
thousand sheep they kind of burst which
which we know and they don't sustain
both those pressure when they are going
to high speed centrifugation and they
burst up so it's important to understand
like these bigger vesicles the crew even
though it isolates a lot of them there's
also some contamination in there so
apart from iam we also wanted to
characterize these from a atomic force
microscopy which gives a nice overview
of the vesicle size and as you can see
we took the fraction seven which is also
the accessible fraction and we
quantified what is the size of these and
and as you can see most of the vesicles
which was present in the in the smaller
density fraction
or the lower density fraction these were
similar to exosomes which were ranging
from 40 to 120 hundred 30 nanometers in
size so when we took at the higher
density fraction and then the same
analysis you can see that these were
again consistent with the electron
microscopy analysis they have a lot of
bigger vesicles which were more than 200
nanometer and fine and the nanometer in
diameter which consistently said that
these are two different types of
vesicles so we did characterization in
terms from the atomic force microscopy
where we wanted to quantify the number
of vesicles which were in the size range
as you can see here 95 98 percent of the
vesicles which are present in the lower
density fraction we're in the range of
30 to 150 nanometers in diameter however
in the larger density fraction most of
the vesicles were more than 100 150
nanometer you can see close to an eighty
ninety percent of them or more than 150
nanometers only ten percent of the
vesicles were less than hundred 50
nanometer so when you see this analysis
you can see that there is still some
vesicles which are smaller than 150 in
the high-density fraction and there is
also some vesicles which are bigger than
the 150 in the in the exosome like
fraction so I can conclude from this
analysis that we have not isolated the
vesicles to opportunity but we have
enriched for them so that's the take
home message from this but we wanted to
identify what could be used as markers
and can we find some markers of these
actors ohms which are not present in
exosomes and vice versa so we start
calling these as small v's or exosomes
and large v's or actors ohms based on
the size range and then we subjected
these two proteomic analysis so now we
wanted to see what are the proteins that
are present in these vesicles subtypes
so then we can make a clear idea what
proteins are present and what can be
called as mark
and and as we have done this on three
cell cell lines where the isolated
exosomes exosomes unten k we can now see
it is general to the cell type and we
can come up with a list of markers so as
you can see in this light compared to
the whole cell lysate there are 591
proteins which were enriched or highly
abundant in X isms similarly compared to
the whole cell lysate there are 558
proteins which are highly enriched in
act isms this clearly says that there is
some kind of sorting or selectivity
mechanisms which is happening in sorting
the protein cargo into this excess of
our vesicles and as a separate project
we are also very much interested in
identifying what are the sorting signals
that kind of targets or directs these
proteins into the exosomes and exercise
most importantly when you compare
between exosomes electro zones you can
see these are clear distinct proteomic
proteomic profile where you can see that
450 proteins we're in eighty percent in
exosomes 1 612 proteins were uniquely
present in activism and this case is
that we can come up with a list of
markers but it's important that it
follows up in multiple cell types rather
than one cell type that's why we wanted
to do more than three more than two and
three sevens so now how do we make sense
of this proteomic data so now we took
those proteins and be known that the
exosomes are indeed formed by the escort
machinery or the multivesicular bodies
so we looked at the the proteins which
are involved in their Scott missionary
and plotted them as this histogram where
you can see in terms of exosomes the
blue color represents the fold ratio of
protein in exosomes compared to ekta
somes meaning here the alex is present
more than 10 for still for abundant in
exosomes compared to vectors ohms
similarly exosomes compared to the 10k
or the crude exosomes you can see in
this figure that alex is more than
fourfold hi
abundant in exosomes compared to the 10k
so likewise when you plotted like this
you can see many of this court
missionary proteins including tsg101 the
dps class of proteins were mostly
enriched in exosomes which kind of kind
of says that the escort missionaries in
the only involved or as much involved in
exorcism biogenesis and not as much in
the ecto Soames and then the proteins
which are exclusively identified in in
exosomes are denoted by an asterisk here
and then a hash is given those those
proteins which are only detected in
Hector's ohms or 10k there is not much
for that only VPS 3070 was identified
one lien episome than actors arms but as
you can see it doesn't not qualify the
twofold ratio so we need not consider
that to be significant but those which
classifies more than two pole be
considered as significant you can see
VPS 32b or chimp faulty was only present
in exosomes not identified in exosomes
or extra zone we further went want to do
the tetraspanin we can know that we do
know that the tetraspanin are important
in excess of by genesis and they're also
being proposed as excess number markers
so we looked at the profile of them and
these are membrane proteins that are
aspiring which are membrane spanning our
domains but when you look at the
exosomes and ekta Soames these are the
extra zones are bigger vesicles while
the ex's owns are smaller so you tend to
see the surface area for exosomes and
exosome there's difference between ian
so you will identify more membrane
proteins in exosomes compared to act
isms this is this goes and saying
because if there is a surface area which
is kind of you can enrich for the
membrane proteins index isms because
they are very less surface area compared
to that prism while we get a lot of
cytosolic and other in solomon are
proteins in reg prisms and this also
goes in saying for the whole self i said
when you tend to identify more
intracellular proteins as opposed to the
membrane proteins so this could be one
by us in the study but
having said that we can see that the
cd81 protein was mainly identified in
excess of the exclusive legend by the
Nexus ohms but not in the episodes but
the other protein cd63 ce9 and other
tetris balance they're there but the
most significant one for RSS cd81 to
respond in 14 and that are spanning nine
but again when you understand how MOSFET
works again mass spectrometry kind of
technologies even though they can
identify a lot of proteins in no time
but they also have some inherent
problems where they suffer in terms of
identifying some of the hydrophobic
amino acids easy so for that methodology
is we have to enrich the membrane
proteins but that could be one of the
bias because why we did not identify
cd63 and CD nine in the preparation as
much as compatible resting again grab
GTP SS which is one of the class of
molecules which are involved in exosomes
and actors and biogenesis you can
clearly see here that the there is a set
of molecules which was extinct
exclusively present in Hector's ohms
this set the ramp molecules and those
RAB molecules which were only
exclusively find in X isms so there is a
set of molecules which are performed
exclusively in there and this was
consistent in two of the cell types most
of the proteins not all of the proteins
most of the proteins were consistent
where it was only present in one of the
extracellular vesicles cell that we're
currently doing some knockdown analysis
and knockout analysis in cell lines to
identify what is the function of these
rags in exosomes and what are the
function of this subset of rats enact
isms and there are other proteins also
which we know about connections and
flatlands and the integral betas and the
vamp molecules we also profile that and
see what is the profile in terms of
exosomes and ekta zones integr in beta
was only present in exosomes but not as
much so based on what current knowledge
from all these slides it's very clear
that what we know is mostly on
ask towards what we know is passed to us
exosomes you know a lot about exosomes
compato eight columns as you can please
see that all the proteins that we know
that only in more in breach and exosomes
and be completely don't know anything
about it deserves so now we wanted to
see the other side of the picture so
what about actors as I said we don't
know too much but there are a handful of
studies like five to six studies which
have done on ekta zones and we wanted to
do literature survey we went on to
collect all those studies we curated
those data and I say curated the data we
looked at the excel sheet and then we
made up the proteins which were known to
be identified adeptus ohms or involved
in the biogenesis of them so one of them
is Arab six as we know of the papers and
porcelain one integrins mmp-2 excess of
a protease and bam three so these are
the list of proteins that we came across
and for the entire list we can download
and this but particular encore target
paper which is currently in press so as
you can see these are the only handful
amount of protein that we could identify
but all of these proteins but more
enriched in exorcisms compact electives
so which is even more shocking because
some of these proteins we thought our
actors over 40's but they're not but
mmp-2 is the one li protein which was
exclusively identified in endosomes but
not in exosomes right this is extra
seller for years it can be separated by
the classical secretory pathway and it
could be an associated molecule also in
terms of actress ohms by why it is
associate volney neckties ohms and not
an exercise is a different question
altogether but we are trying to address
that as well so now based on the
proteomic study this is what we kind of
think these could be some of the
potential markers of vector zones I
named potential because some of these
markers may not stay same with many
tests multiple cell types but cd81 was
consistently present in exosomes but not
identified in the larger vesicles
similarly we got the dps the escort
missionary he is 24 36 the tetraspanin
ce9 and
14 the symptom on the integral about 34
active zones we think mmv to is one of
the good molecule but similarly we have
the rad GPSS and then the spectrums
mucins and cytokeratin 18 and the
ribosomal 14 9 and 18 so there's also
two other studies which are performed by
colleagues one is from booting theories
group most of you know her as she is a
well-known scientist in his field who
has been working on this field for a
very long time and that they have also
isolated exosomes and larger vesicles
and their results also correlate exactly
with in terms of cd81 and they have done
a nice study also where they're isolated
exosomes from multiple cell types and
they were proven that these markers
could be validated in Weston but you can
study the hub paper in when it comes out
more detail currently probably it's in
review or impress similarly another
group from US dollar SGD CEO from LA she
also isolated exosomes and Uncas ohms
and she was able to show that site
accordion 18 was present in the larger
vesicle venomoth not was absent in
excellence but one thing which we notice
this crack in 18 is an epithelial marker
so fibroblast cells may not separate
them and so it cannot be used as an
exorcism a marker in lot of cell types
but at least in epithelial cells we
don't see karate late in secreting in
multiple exosomes but mainly like in
nectar zones and epithelial cell you can
see a Western here to confirm that I can
see the G GM 130 was not finding any of
the vesicle fractions between personal
also lies it but the mmp-2 was fine only
in Hector zones and 10k but not in
exosomes similarly the cd81 was one we
found and exosomes are not in exosomes
and 10k again validating the proteomic
analysis that we have done so all of
this data for this three cell lines is
available of supplementary information
in the on / target publications that I
presented so we've moved on further to
study one of the functional role of
exosomes and act isms because we know
about something about the programming
profile of exosomes but what do they
functionally do is there any functional
distinction between these two vesicle
subtypes so we use this program for
underage which is developed by a lab
which does the functional enrichment
analysis where you can put your extra
seller vesicle data from whatever or mix
technologies you do and then you can do
an enrichment analysis of what are the
classes which are underrepresented or
all represented in your class and it can
give a p-value and a nice figure a
publishable quality where you can put
that in the manuscript and this is what
we have done as you can see the escort
missionary was enriched in exosomes and
not in the echo zones and similarly many
of the signaling molecules the plasma
membrane proteins all of them were
enriching exosomes compared to the ekta
somes in Ekta zones we get proteins
implicated in gene expression
translation of those where the molecules
which were enriched in them again as I
said before this they the enrichment of
the plasma membrane protein signaling
molecules could be partly due to the
surface area of exosomes and if rhythms
that would be one reason but we also
think that exosomes probably have more
signaling implications than ekta somes
from the programming profile that we see
then we also looked at the biological
processes that are enriched and depleted
in exosomes here we are comparing
exosomes versus active zones you can see
the metabolism proteins which are
implicated in metabolism are depleted in
exosomes while they are enriched in
ectotherms but as I said proteins which
are implicated in cell proliferation
signaling immune response signal
transduction protein transport and
enzyme receptor signaling pathway
they're all enriched in exosomes come
back to the egg prisms
and now this is another slide which
shows the molecular function which are
the molecular function terms which are
enriched and depleted similar to that
the you can see lot of enzyme activities
are enriched in the actors ohms but here
again the transmembrane protein the
signaling axis is kind of enriched in
the accessible cargo so now we have done
this one but we wanted to identify the
mutant proteins which are separated by
our CDs so again when you talk about
exosomes and mechanisms we all know
there are a lot of disease proteins
which are implicated in disease being
secreted out of v's so we all we have to
have a prior knowledge for example if
you're looking at approaching EGFR
mutation we need to have a prior
knowledge for looking into what Newton
protein or what oncogenic molecule is
secreted out of v's but if is that a
methodology where we can identify this
in an unbiased in a global way for that
we started using the proto genomic
analysis where we correlate the
proteomic data with the genomic and
transcriptomic data to identify the
mutations as well as to enhance the
genome annotation qualities so this
particular methodology has been
available for quite some time in the
field but not has been nobody has used
this in the context of extracellular
vesicles so we said I published a paper
in 2012 where I use this particular
methodology in identifying fusion genes
mutated or truncated proteins in
colorectal cancer proteomics samples and
I published that as a methodology and
those interested can go and look at this
particular article but I didn't call it
as for a genomics at that time but we
call it as identification of mutant
proteins at that time but now the word
proto genomics have caught up and then
people are using it so the take-home
message is being used on the proteomic
data from 18 color to cancer cell lines
identify the mutant proteins which are
being secreted out and and we also
describe the method
how we did that and so similarly what we
did in this case is we had the
neuroblastoma cell line as such by why
right and we did an exome sequencing of
that particular cell line so what exome
sequencing does is it will identify all
the mutations which are presented in
present in the coding regions or the G
or what you think is the gene regions
which goes for a protein in the
particular cell line so once you have
the coding mutation which are which
could be the single nucleotide
variations or it could be the insertions
and deletions in the particular genome
we made a protein database of those of
the particular exome sequencing data
then we isolated exosomes actors ohms
and then the whole cell lysate to the
proteomic analysis as i showed before
and we searched this protonic data with
the mutant database and they ended up
I'd identifying lot of mutant proteins
which are separated out of exosomes and
actress ohms so this is a powerful
technique like in terms if you want to
identify which could be a mutant protein
we can use this easily because now there
are like some sequencing data is
available for a lot of cell lines
publicly and then all you need to do is
have a proteomic data from your exosomes
all your rectus ohms and they can
anybody can do this analysis and then
you can identify the mutant proteins
that are setting it out of this vesicle
types so on this representation answer
cause plot of the mutations that we have
identified in this again this is a
pretty picture but you can zoom in and
look at it but in this case you can do
this kind of representation is what I'm
trying to address by this particular
slide so what we identified is through
exosomes we saw a lot of proteins which
are mutant protein which has secreted
out all these proteins have been
implicated in oncogenesis drug
resistance and kind of metastasis as
well similarly we also identify a set of
proteins which are separated out of
ectotherms we are doing functional
analysis of what is the function of this
mutant proteins in the recipient self
for example one of our interest is Vince
signaling pathway and we have looked
unidentified that the mutant
beta-catenin is secreted out from
colorectal cancer cell lines and then we
take this exercise which contained the
mutant vida Catalan and incubate that
with the recipient cell we can induce
wind signaling pathway in the recipient
cell so this is beautiful when you say
there's a mutant protein which is
constitutively active but and that can
be transferred to the recipient cell and
the function of that particular protein
is again amplified in the recipient cell
and imagine that in the tumor micro
moment and that is immense where the
cancer cells can evade multiple
mechanisms where they can keep this the
cell symptoms of the flu proliferative
mechanism for a constant time so again
the protea genomic analysis of EBS it
can be used to run it upon neutral
proteins and you can identify DC
specific biomarkers like say if you have
a mutant protein the lot of bamako field
if we talk about we always have issues
with specificity how specific is a
biomarker for a particular disease right
so now when you identify a mutant
protein or a mutant RNA which is being
transferred by all the v's and it's also
identified in plasma or many other
bodily fluids you would get the
specificity which is currently lacking
in many other kind of techniques because
these DC specific or mutant protein are
RNA would be made up only in the DC cell
all right so you would get the
specificity that is required so I can
read this to reviews if you are
interested in this particular analysis
so now they wanted to see what is the
oncogenic potential of this v's so be as
I said before the exosomes have a lot of
signaling proteins in them but the echo
zones did not have much but when we
looked at the cosmic database which has
a lot of oncogenic mutations which are
present in many cancer types we
downloaded the data we only took at look
at the significant list and overlays
overlaid those proteins which are known
to be implicated in any particular
cancer for example this is the list of
protein
which are implicated in thyroid cancer
and we overlaid that on exosomes and
ecto some data from a proteomic results
from this you can see that you can see a
lot of blue compared to read the blue
means this is actors of exosomes and the
red is active zones they can see most of
the proteins which are implicated in
cancer of all identified or mostly
identified in exosomes compared to act
isms and this clearly says in this
particular thing that exosomes have more
company cargo than eight columns we
further went on to do the same analysis
with estd in which is expressed sequence
tags and that is also analyzed from
normal tissues as well as from cancer
and diseased tissues as you can see
consistently these proteins again are
more pounding exosomes compared to
detect isms so are these are by
informatik analysis and the statistical
value was quiet good indeed and it
convinced us enough to do some
experiments and to see what is the
difference in terms of the oncogenic
potential between boosting bicycle types
so we did a proliferation assay where
the isolated exosomes from the x y
sirloins we incubated that with
neuroblastoma cell line called b2 which
is already in aggressive cell type as
you can see here the untreated cell is
here since the control but when he
treated the cells with actors ohms the
proliferation the for proliferation end
up but the actors on the exosome
treatment you can see there's more than
two-fold proliferation and it was a
significant one compared to that
untreated self when he compared between
exosomes the nectar zones that's
different definitely not a big
significant difference between these two
but exosomes were significantly inducing
more proliferation in the recipient cell
compared to the and drink itself the
biggest question on these kind of asses
right so because being incubated with 40
microgram per mil but having said that
is this concentration physiologically
relevant right so be kind of incubate
200 microgram free in the micro gram for
under my program at any one time part
and then we say oh we see all this
Shin allottees but I I think we should
be very caution we should be very big
but caution about what we are trying to
do because some of the concentration
that we are using may not be
physiologically relevant because the
biggest question currently in this field
is what is the concentration of the
exosomes of the EDS that is being
secreted out in the cells in Bible and
what is the physiological concentration
so for us until we answer that it's
better to go with a slower as we can and
we also can use higher concentration but
try to use a lower concentration also
and show that the signal is starting
from there and not to try to use a
higher concentration and stick with the
signal and so we also went on to do a
migratory analysis where we wanted to
see the role of exosomes in inducing
migration as you can see here the
untreated cells uses control where you
can see the there is a scratch in the
cells and then the depth it for 24 hours
and then saw how the world was healing
and when we treated this cells with ekta
zones you can see the wound was closing
but not as significantly but when we
treated the same with exosomes we can
see there's a significant difference and
you can see that the wound was even
closing more clearly showing that the
ex's owns induce more migration than
actives we also did that with 10k the
crew exosomes and we repeated this as I
said here you can see it's 40 micro gram
we went to a lower concentration of 20
microgram per little and then you can
see here the 10k and the actors ohms did
not have a significant effect while the
ex's ohms indeed add a significant
effect in inducing migration in the
recipient cells so this confirmed that
consistent with the bioinformatic
analysis that the exosomes are more
oncogenic where they can induce more
migration and proliferation why
proliferation cannot be tagged as an
oncogenic oncogenic potential but the
migration is we also get an invasion
assay where we also show that exosomes
could have more
invasive potential ban the Equus ohms
but the summary to give a summary the
talk so you can see Alex and TJ 101 or
enrich nexus ohms and not Marcus of
exosomes so you can call them as
Enbridge proteins and you can see the
minimal requirements by lot wall and
floor filled and by the scientific board
of ICF where they talk about this
particular thing that Alex engagement
all enriched and cd81 could be used as
accessible markers and MLB to as
ectodermal markers but again more
studies need to be done as of now with
three studies we can see that cd81 is
quite this thing when mmp-2 we have done
it but in 3 cell types but we need more
studies on this as well and annexes ohms
are enriched in membrane proteins and
signal transduction molecules compared
to the ector zones and exosomes are more
unfortunate than exosomes so this just
like to acknowledge people who did the
work two postdocs shook motley takuma
who's a band from my exposed or and like
you two who did all the experiments
involved in this project along with the
students michael them and family and
thanks the funding agencies and thank
you all for listening and happy to take
any questions very good thank you for
that for highly informative presentation
dr. matt van we've already had more than
60 questions come in to our feed here so
far so a very stimulating so very
stimulating a presentation to say the
least for those of you who have not had
the opportunity a opportunity to ask a
question please use the blue Q&A button
at the lower left of your presentation
window we'll go ahead and get started on
the Q&A session the first question is
how does the isolation of exosomes and
exosomes affect the vesicles function
can one expect to isolate and then
reintroduce them into cell cultures or a
model organism and get physiologically
reliable results yeah thanks for the
question Chad thanks for the question
sir the question here is how does the
isolation of exosomes and exosomes
effective vesicle function can one
expect to isolate and then reintroduce
them into the cell cultures or a model
organism and get physiologically
reliable results and that's a good
question indeed and so again the exosome
isolation method definitely will affect
the function of the vesicles because now
when I say the function of vesicles and
when you when you choose a method of
isolation it depends on what basically
are getting for example if you're doing
an immunoaffinity method rights for
example you're isolating exosomes by
cd63 positive exosomes you're only going
to isolate cd63 positive exosomes and
then you are neglecting a population of
cd- c63 negative exosomes so when you
take the cdc 3 x's ohms and then you
incubate on the target cells and look
for a physiological function or any
function in that setting you are just
going to buy us the whole thing because
your methodology that he used was an
amino affinity and you ignore the other
population similarly when you on
ultracentrifugation again you might
collect down some of the complexes in
there so they might buy us the results
in a way so the answer to the first part
of the question is yes if you will the
methodology that you're using is very
important for the vesicle function and
for the second question in terms of do
we get physiologically reliable results
when you're integrating on the cell
cultures and one wrong medicine again
this is a question of which everyone is
trying to understand because we don't
know the physiological concentration one
thing we notice exosomes or any other
leadies that we think this
constitutively secreted but now we are
giving when we're doing all this essays
in Bitra we are incubating the exosomes
with the target cells for one time point
and then we are giving one dosage and so
sometimes we give up more sometimes we
keep this but as you can think this is
happening constitutively in in bible you
can think that can compensate to an
extent but having said that that
question is is debatable and we don't
know the answer for it yet so that's one
question which which a lot of people are
trying to answer and I'm thinking that's
one which is not going to be easy to
answer because for first we need to
understand what is the physiological
concentration of peds in the normal and
then what is the role of the v's in
physiological conditions even in
homeostasis and things like that before
trying to goad it but very question that
very good question indeed we need to
keep that in mind before performing our
designing any essay thanks great thank
you for that response there several
questions have come in regarding the
stability of exosomes stability in cell
media and your freezer and free stall
cycles as well can you comment on this
yes so that is one important question as
well so a prior to that so we stability
there are three or four papers which are
currently out there in the literature
where talks where it talks about
stability people have done the
freeze-thaw cycle where they kind of
take exosomes from the freezer and do a
repetitive resource liking but does not
affect the exosome stability as much and
but people have also incubated the
exosomes and minus 80 for a longer
period of time and look in terms of the
protein markers inside them and we are
one of them and we can say that it was
stable however they haven't looked at
the membrane proteins so the membrane
proteins we don't know how that they are
and how well they affect the uptake but
when we didn't uptake assay for those
exosomes which were preserved or frozen
down for three months in- IT they were
having similar uptake efficiency as that
of the cell that of the other exosomes
which was given on the zero day as well
but as i said before the functionality
right a functionality is a different
question altogether where a lot of
people have shown that the exosomes are
not as functional as they used to be
when they are at zero days when you when
you freeze them for a longer period so
bc that consistently as well when we
keep them for up to three to four weeks
we are getting some of the functionality
but when we do more than that we don't
see the same amount of response which we
used to see it before so what we do
currently in the lab is we try to not
keep texts ohms if it is a functional
study for more than two to three weeks
maximum two weeks we try to keep that
but if it is a biomarker or a proteomic
profiling of those kind of study then
again you can probably go up to three to
four weeks but it's advisable to do
these kind of essays and ass and then
but the good thing is the exes ohms are
much more stable than what we taught off
they are really stable but having said
that we need to have our precautions as
well Thanks great thanks for that we are
running low on time we'll ask one more
question here and that question is does
the proteome analysis of exosomes give
any clues about the cell entry mechanism
yes that's the good question indeed and
that is again one of the two areas that
might have this concentrating on and but
what does because now when you see at
the when you see the proteomic profile
of eb's or exosomes in general you
change the growth factor you kind of
change any kind of setting you induce
hypoxia you kind of give you knock out
some protein the protein we profile
completely changes irrespective of what
is it so it is clear that the membrane
proteins are also changing as we all
know the membrane proteins have a more
important role in the target cell fusion
uptake or in terms of entry and that can
give us clues but having said that there
is also a lot of proteins which are
known to be involved in pi genesis but
if as the question is in terms of clues
yes it does give clues but having said
that and you need to be careful because
now you have a lot of proteins which are
generally present in exosomes which can
have while Genesis may not have an
effect in terms of uptake Plus also and
there are some proteins which are
specifically present for a particular
cell type and so we kind of do knockout
analysis of some of these membrane
proteins and see how the uptake
specificity changes yeah that's that's
pretty much where it is that we
definitely have clues from the proteomic
analysis and even from the lipid ohmic
analysis how the lipid only
fun changes and then the uptake
efficiency changes as well Thanks great
thanks again unfortunately we are out of
time I want to thank the audience for
the interesting questions and
participation in today's event I would
also like to thank our sponsor beckman
coulter and of course dr. Suresh math
event and for making today's educational
webcast possible which will also be
available for onto my on the man viewing
through beckman coulter Tom thanks again
goodbye